toutes les bouteilles plastiques voilà
ce qui se recycle pas parce qu'il peut
être jeté c'est fabio des grades qui va
mettre des années voilà ce qu'on peut
voyager dans la loire n'a heureusement
une cinquantaine de bénévoles est venu
prêter main forte à la mairie et le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'ils ne
se sont pas déplacés pour rien parmi eux
les scouts et guides de france qui était
déterminée à nettoyer les quais pour
leur première activité de l'année
suite aux corridas ne s'est pas revu
donc c'est la première fois qu'on se
revoie et faire une activité citoyenne
c'est vraiment ce que c'est c'est
vraiment nos valeurs chez les scouts
depuis plus de 15 ans les chinois
n'avaient pas accès à la loire le fleuve
était dissimulée derrière une forêt en
friche les arbres ont été déracinés cet
été mais tout n'a pas été
dévégétalisation pour permettre à une
nouvelle population de ne pas être
déstabilisé il semblerait qu'une
colonies de castors y est installé leur
domicile
donc voilà on a laissé un peu de
végétation justement pour qu'elles que
cette colonie puisse vivre paisiblement
le reprendra ses droits mi-septembre
avec ouverture d'un barrage alors toute
cette opération va permettre de limiter
les nombreux déchets qui se déverseront
dans la loire et qui peut-être finiront
leur course dans l'océan atlantique